a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti avessero
video sono fa vj può mettere questa roba
perché non si poteva vedere il mio cuoio
capelluto era inguardabile ciò questa
soluzione momentanea perdonate insieme
tradizione stanley per ball avevo
soltanto fatto due finali ragazzi di
estranei barboni e ne mancano altri due
credo non so se ce ne sono poi altri
però che io sappia
ne mancano almeno due quindi i ragazzi
torniamo dov'eravamo rimasti allora
dettagli parabole per chi non avesse
visto altro episodio è la storia di
quest'uomo che lavora nel suo ufficio e
per anni lavora nel suo ufficio
digitando sulla tastiera è un bel di noi
arrivano più compiti da eseguire si
accorge che non c'è più nessuno negli
uffici e tenta di trovare la via
d'uscita insomma da questo ufficio dal
quale non è mai uscita non ha fatto
niente altro che digitare sulla tastiera
e o rimasti che per la mente era
riuscito ad uscire però c'erano altre
cose da fare che non ho fatto
faccio una precisazione ragazzi siccome
è un gioco narrato ci sono delle volte
in cui leggo e quindi dovresti leggere
anche voi perché non posso ovviamente
parlare sopra il narratore sono farebbe
schifo la cosa come ho detto la volta
scorsa se non sapete leggere andate a
scuola impara da legge e poi guardate
questo video quindi ragazzi avevo fatto
praticamente tutto quello che ha chiesto
il tizio che parla e stavolta prova a
fare un po di te la senti through the
man's land section devo tornare nel mio
percorso non davanti noi invece prendo
l'ascensore ragazzi non l'ho mai non
hanno ancora fatto sta scelta non so
dove mi porta non ne ho la più pallida
idea
le alghe grassi ci hai messo leggermente
un po a capire o nell album state
esattamente quanto il cranio ti faccia
vuoi le sbagliato ragazzi capita tutti e
ci mancherebbe
sentite capiamoci perché veramente ti
stupro la nonna
manca solo st porta se sin deficiente e
saracinesca ma che cazzo lo usa più
ma vecchio e c'è un camion posso farti
camion e andar via ma io non ho capito
se si è tornati qua ma no non dovrei
essere qui mi ha detto di chiudere gli
occhi ragazzi ho chiuso gli occhi
oddio suisse topiche in from the
beginning
no no no no fermo fermo fermo fanno
ripartire no non ripartire già l'ammazzo
no ma perché non ha ricominciato
realmente stava fingendo stanley degli
ucci ingenito in anno io non ho cambiato
il mio l'ho fatto camst n
l'ex find the cure cioè è diventata un
avventura cercando di trovare la storia
io mi hai aperto 800 forte ma che ne so
io non ricomincia no a ricominciare di
nuovo anno non lo fa
devo passare la giornata così non
ditemelo ditemelo print inoha
tranquillità
sono io che gioco ci manca adesso non ci
sono neanche più le porte
il suo prezzo anche il narratore si è
perso e questo il problema
che cosa ti devo dire cosa abbiamo perso
tutto uguale io ho tentato di fare tutto
come i'm with me non arrivato da qua io
scusami com'è possibile
mosca ha fatto più spesso lo sa non lo
so io non lo so io riesce a ricordare
sia un ufficio ora eravamo prima
nell'ufficio siamo in questa catapecchia
che manco gli horror famosi
wen si stai dando soddisfazione fratello
libero grazie grazie grazie
ma non c'è niente di onesto ma diver a
me non avrei mai deve ricominciare
però basta a questa l'ultima giuro che
se ricominci poi un'altra volta spengo
tutto accada un cazzo ok adesso la linea
che adesso capiamo dove andare online
altro che la sostituzione questa volta
pratica in guarda tu sei lì solo alla
linea trademark col trademark senza
nessuna proprio passione va bene io
segue la linea che ti devo dire
quindi se io cambio strada mentre la
linea mi dice di andare lì trovai a va
bene dai segua da lì per stavolta segue
la linea perché mi hai mandato in pappa
il cervello prima quindi va bene per
adesso segua la linea poi vabbè vedi la
linea atm sempre tm sa dove la storia
deve essere in quella direzione avanti
stanley yusuf fort apache non poteva
passare sulla scatola dovuto fare gli
facciamo il giro farneticando cagare
l'mit folders chain store successo
cercato di segue no come fa sapere che
lo spegne random impossibile ragazza
drogando servizio come faccio cos'è per
te ma chi è che ha fatto starò a ragazzi
ed io è la linea atm si sta drogando
no ragazzi dei problemi ci sono dei
problemi in corso abbiate pazienza e
niente sta cazzo di musica vi prego già
la linea in semi stava andando in pappa
al cervello per cortesia chi è che ha
tracciato sta roba
tanto sui tubi sì sì sì credo faccia zig
zag per carità togliete la musica mi dà
fastidio per cortesia ha voglia di
spiegarmi perché sto facendo questo
accordo sempre che cazzo sto seguendo
una linea che tracciata sul soffitto
nella sala sta faccenda di via stanley
paraboschi sta sfuggendo di mano ragazzi
lo sto capendo più niente
dovevo guardare la pianta questa stelle
sarà molto importante piantina sale
senza fini esaminare attentamente di
ricordarla x men e non vorrei certo
perda qualcosa io mi devo ricordare
questa è l'unica roba che mi vien in
mente per ricordarmelo e fare la foto
col telefono perché che cazzo ne so e
sono tornati in giro ti ammazzo ti
ammazzo abbiamo fatto sta roba per
qualcosa o poi è servita un cazzo ancora
ma come hai potuto farci questo ma zio
toni il problema non era la linea altre
me che ho dovuto si prega non ce la
faccio più no basta basta mi sono rotto
il cazzo mi sono rotto le palle non la
seguo più ma cosa è un western e hi tech
i cileni 89 che hai studiato ad harvard
perché non potremmo inventarci la stessa
storia qualcosa di eccitante audace e
misterioso disler action one direction
al ragazzo per me non c'è problema
1 dio e che che potrebbe to di nuovo
tutti n perché basta che la ignori ok
ragno non vedo la possibilità di poterla
seguire zio a meno che non sia spider
man
mi prendi per il culo zio ragazzi mi sta
facendo seriamente camminare il ritorno
per un minuto
la porta a destra ap quello che vuoi
apri qualche bravo va bene conflitto e
confusione il million ending cosa stato
mi disse da quanto sto giocando sa cosa
ed effettivamente così ragazzi cioè che
in passato veramente subendo forti o
[ __ ] abbiamo spezzato il circolo perché
non voler iniziare il gioco abbiamo
rotto il gioco in poche parole che è
successo solo legge stava leggendo
tranquilla mieri miseria che è successo
stavo leggendo il mentre che leggero
siamo ripartiti fantastico quindi niente
il gioco si è riavviato questo era il
finale confuso abbiamo fatto il finale
confuso che è alquanto strano ma parere
su questo forti una domanda ma la pianta
che mi hai fatto fotografare prima che
cazzo serve ci siamo ragazzi continuano
dall'ultima volta che dovevamo scegliere
la porta rossa o la borsa bisogno che io
avevo scelto quella blu ovviamente
adesso stavolta problema andare in
quella roccia le pene che succedono
sempre desiderato che tu sia speso in
sensi io non ho mai messo in dubbio
questa cosa vai tranquillo
cosa vuoi dirmi grazie e buio però
dentro lo stesso pre buio dove si sa se
mi fa ripartire mi incazzo così nuova
break e figo
e perché se rimane o semplicemente quale
credo di sentirmi felice ma la fonte se
gaio f.no maria io esco grazie andando
via mi faceva cagare zio e abbi pazienza
non c'è verso a posso suicidarmi ma come
ma vedrai suicidiamo ci sarà ancora vivo
il sopravvissuto mi ha fatto davvero
preoccupare adesso possiamo tornare alla
stanza di prima miri sui cd mastramico
gli uffici dagli uffici di finto
suicidio
i suoi sede the search continuerà a
suicidarmi che non muoio sul serio che
si uccide piuttosto che vedermi felice è
davvero questa la situazione fisio ma
come sono morto sul serio la fiamma
mikami suicidato 600 volte quindi questa
è il finale suicidio ragazzi eravamo
arrivati al alla stanza del controllo
della mente seguendo tutto quello che ha
detto stanley però c'è che stasera da
qualche mi ricordavo che non avevo
ancora preso per niente anche se questo
passaggio alla scritta choose perdendo
peso o stern insomma vale troverà solo
una morte violenta fotte 6 da zio è
tanto il corridoio in lungo 15 possiamo
arrivare tranquillamente non arriverò
alla morte violenta perché io sono
stanley stanley non può morire così a me
avevo ancora l'opportunità di voltarsi e
tornare sui binari ormai ho preso la mia
scelta
forlan da morti della madonna zio cosa
pensi che ci sia un corridoio buio e
basta forse non è un corridoio buio per
caso c'è la morte qui sotto perché il
tizio ha detto che sarei morto
che è successo
sono morto alla fine ci aveva ragione
lui mi sa non possono morire così sono
fornivo seriamente la madonna o fatta a
sopravvivere nelle cinque sedi più alla
sua figlia di se stesso come la sua vita
fosse priva di conseguenze madonna forse
la sua morte non è poi tanto importanza
ragazzi stavo scherzando
oddio sentite va bene posso andare e
tornare indietro se volete ma cazzo sono
vivo farewell stanley leitner stanley
sono vivo ma quella tizia che ha parlato
tra l'altro non era la nardò è una nuova
narratrice di stanley park il beach
fiume neva chi ne soffre ma chi è sta
tizia che sta parlando spiegato in
attimo off o spento tutto
poi c'è scritto devo uscire dal gioco
prima di ragazzi ho stoppato io sul
serio perché la tizia mi ha detto che
devo uscire perché se non esco dal gioco
continuerò ma [ __ ] io voglio
continuare a giocare anche se significa
essere intrappolato in un loop eterno
voglio continuare a giocare qui è il
problema
questo è il problema
chicche sono morto non vedo più niente
perché sono giustamente morto propri
cazzo sono morto sul serio c'è il gioco
è rimasto nero per anni e io ho
continuato a giocare sul nero per ora
però il gioco è finito fantastico e il
finale più vero che esista in un
videogame perché quando muore qualcuno
in genere poi si vedono storie invece
possono morta è diventato tutto nero lo
schermo quindi realistico al 200 per
cento meravigliosa anche ragazzi non
credo che l'episodio è stato figo perché
ho provato altri non so se ce ne sono e
ce ne sono anche altri di finali perché
enormi e pazzesco che spero che vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi cos'è questo video
piuttosto momento ero mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook e come il video
trattando iscrizione senza il city
scatti ci vediamo così umido ma non vedo
un cazzo questo caso adesso è morto
anche il telecomando anche lui vede nero
e vai e pazienza se rischiate ci vediamo
al prossimo video